yeah i i'm really gonna do this
but before i do that this episode
kind of almost sorta has a sponsor so
um i have i've gotten into a
partner affiliate program with humble
bundle
now this is not something that i'm going
to plug every single
video that i put up but when there are
um things that i think are relevant
to um my subscriber base on humble
bundle i'm gonna
bring to you them to your attention and
there's gonna be an affiliate link
down in the description and if you go to
humble bundle
through that link and make your purchase
that way
that does help me um that that
you know assist me and that gives me a
that gives me a small financial boost
you know i'm not they're not a sponsor
in so far as
i'm not strictly speaking being paid to
talk about this
but if you do if you choose to support
humble bundle
and do it through the link that'll be in
the description that does actually help
me
um if you don't know what humble bundle
is it's basically kind of a it's a
charity fundraising
um style thing where they basically put
together
a whole bunch of themed stuff sometimes
it's a whole bunch of video game stuff
you know sometimes it's themed around
franchises
and what have you and you pay you decide
how much you pay for it now how much you
pay
does determine how much you get but you
will get
something you will get something related
to whatever the thing is and in this
particular case
um there is a humble bundle that runs
through
i believe through the first week of
october
that is for doctor who comics which is
are not something that i've talked about
before i am gonna
um work on talking about something
related to that
um in the not so distant future so i can
kind of get a baseline going on that but
the thing is humble model actually
reached out to me before
um a month or two back when they ran
something for big finish audio stuff
and i didn't sign up for the affiliate
thing at that point because i knew what
humble bundle was and i had heard good
things
but i've never purchased anything
through them i didn't know what the
experience was like
actually buying a humble bundle i
actually did
with that um doctor who audio thing and
i got a whole bunch of stuff including
some torchwood audios which i
i didn't have and hadn't planned to get
to but now i have some so i'll be able
to do that now
so i've got i i've now bought the
experience and so now i feel comfortable
because
even though as much as i would honestly
really kind of love sponsors i would
love to find a way to make my living off
this
i've been approached by a number of
companies before about
you know links for you know and coupon
codes or you know sponsoring a video or
or what have you but when i've looked
into the companies they've
they they haven't made me comfortable
like they
i would look into them and go ah like
i'm looking at your
your consumer experiences there's some
red flags here for me so i'm not going
to name any of those
companies because that's not fair to
them but this was the first where i like
i looked into it went through the
experience of buying through them and
went
yeah i feel comfortable actually
associating with that so
i'm making you aware and so yeah
humble bundle link doctor who comic book
material
check it out and if you're interested in
doing it you are supporting charities
you get a whole bunch
no matter what tier you go with you get
a whole bunch of stuff for the money
that you spend and
yeah you'd be helping me out a little
bit okay that's enough of that that was
probably really awkward i'm not used to
plugging stuff that isn't my own stuff
on here hopefully if i ever do something
like this again it will be smoother
let's move on
it's true i am about to overanalyze a
tiny section of a scene from the
upcoming premiere
of doctor who normally i i try not to
indulge in this it seems
just like excessive but i'm sorry i'm
really excited for this plus
it does actually touch on something that
i have said that i wanted it it kind of
gives it to me assuming that what we see
of it here
is pretty much the extent of it now i
have said in the past and i'm talking
about the the sort of first look preview
thing that came out for
the woman who fell to earth it's sort of
like a one scene thing it's it's
in a dark it looks like it's uh it's in
a subway car
um and you know it's dark the lights are
out the doctor's there and we've got two
of the characters who are going to
become
companions sort of going hey what what
are you doing here what's going on
there's just a little
interaction a little banter back and
forth with them so
uh in looking at this scene um i have
said
previously that i want the doctor's
change of gender
to be addressed as minimally as
possible i want as little emphasis put
on this
as can be gotten away with not
necessarily because i think there's no
value in delving into this change more
but because
i don't trust chris chibnall to
tackle that not at this point i mean
you know maybe i can gain that
confidence over time maybe he'll
actually
go the distance and do it and it'll work
i don't know i don't have the faith in
him to be able to tackle that
so i've said before i really want as
little as possible the way that it's
handled here
in this clip is exactly what i want
especially if this is all it is
which is that they're like madam you
know where where are you going she was
why are you calling me madam because
you're a woman
am i does it suit me
and that that's perfect like that that
that moment like the only point of
concern is oh
is it working for me it's it's very
reminiscent of tenant like am i
ginger or um you know just
smith going through his body knows i've
had worse chin
blimey you know i l and i love that sort
of
concern and and it it doesn't even
i i haven't looked at other people's
analysis of these things and
so you know even some channels that i
follow do this but i really make a point
of not looking at that stuff before i
get my own video out because i want it
very much to be my own thoughts so i
have no idea if people have looked into
this too hard i could imagine a scenario
which people like oh yeah
now that now that the doctor's a woman
is all concerned about
the appearance and oh she's going to be
obsessed with that except the doctor's
almost always concerned
about their his appearance whenever he's
been regenerated at least in modern era
he has been so this has been hammered on
for a while
even eccleston who he didn't even see
the regeneration into
he gets a look at a mirror and rosie
goes oh it's not too bad shame about the
ears you know this is
this is an ongoing thing so and this
this feels
just right again
if it's pretty much the full extent of
the dealing with
the change in gender at least for this
series like
eventually if they want to have the
doctor run into a former companion and
like
you can have it come up a little bit
through that companions eyes i'll be
okay with that
but i want the doctor herself to address
it as little as possible
moving on from that because i liked that
um the rest of what i see
seems fine um nothing
that i'm too worried about and um a few
things that i'm like oh i hope that
doesn't go on too long they seem to be
doing the doctor
amnesia amnesia and why can't i
speak all of a sudden amnesia ish
thing that happens occasionally and
i'm i'm generally not a fan of it like i
if i were to guess i would say
they're hoping that this new that series
11 is going to serve as a jumping
on point for a lot of new viewers and
they're probably going to use the doctor
realizing who she is as a way to
present more stuff to audiences for the
first time
kind of like a little bit how um with
the 11th hour with matt smith's first
episode
uh they really filtered through amelia
pond the doctor
explaining pretty much everything that
he is now you can still do that through
the companions
i think they they seem to be preferring
to do it through the doctor in a sense
of self-discovery so
narratively i get it um and
yes i realize i'm over analyzing this
don't tell me that i know
i i'm part of the problem i realize that
but
if it's so i i get it but at the same
time i don't
i don't like the doctor with amnesia i
didn't like it in the
doctor who movie i don't like it you
know in general with the
you know i i like the doctor realizing
what kind of doctor
he now she is going to be i like that
lieutenant when
you know the the sticker are yelling at
him who are you goes i don't know
or you know with capaldi you know going
door
not me he goes out the window me and you
know
that sort of realizing who they are as
they go along i love
that but actually going to the step of
the of not even knowing who she is
is um i don't know feels like an
overstep again we'll see it actually
it's
all execution dependent not a lot to go
off of with the
um with the new companions so far they
seem fine
from what little i've seen um they seem
prepared to roll with some weirdness at
least a certain degree of it
like a woman asking what it is called
another moment i don't love but is
mercifully over kind of quick and i do
like her
comeback um when she gets told that oh
good boy biology
so like i'm i'm liking that those sorts
of bits of banter and
i'm i'm hopeful
based off this cliff cliff clip i don't
i
i am not drunk i swear i don't know
what's wrong with me tonight
um but in any case i i do think this
clip
is solid and having you know
looked at it more times than i should
and now
over analyzed it for you folks um it
does not dampen my enthusiasm
at all i am really excited
for the new season of doctor who it is
yeah i'm i'm pumped for this
and it it just it
it can't come here soon enough i want to
sit down and i want to get to know
this doctor so badly
so those are my thoughts on this little
first look clip thing
that we got i
i'm gonna try and not do any more
unexpected doctor who videos between now
and when the uh the first episode
premieres so you know you'll get the
overdue
who review on wednesday i'm
i'm really debating whether
i'm going to do i've what because
because i have i'm gonna have to do the
reviews of the new episodes those are
gonna have to come out on monday
they just are um i'm not gonna like
given the air time especially of the
premiere because they're doing you know
a simulcast thing
i i could theoretically have it up later
in the day on sunday but i don't want to
do that fast to turn around i don't like
turning around something in less than 24
hours it's just not
fun for me so you know i'm kicking it to
monday i know i'm doing that what i
haven't
i'm going back and forth on is whether
or not i'm still going to have a doctor
who video out
on sunday which is what i've been doing
for a very long time
um i don't know
i don't know because if i if i keep that
while the new series is airing that
means i'm doing three doctor who videos
a week and that
feels like overload like i i know that a
lot of people know me primarily as a
as a youtuber as a doctor who channel
but
like ah i don't know but then again it
would only be
three for as long as the new series runs
i don't know i'm going back and forth so
if you have thoughts on that as well as
this clip
by all means share them so whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of other stuff you can do because
there's buttons and there's links
including a link to the patreon
also your little reminder the humble
bundle it is and the link is down below
so
check that out if you didn't already if
you feel like it if you don't don't
worry about it because
you folks you're the council and i just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
go
[Music]
you